the turnstile tech here how does that
change
your prep process as a director are we
talking basically like
like doubling your storyboards uh
good question i hadn't i i did have a
an intent early on when i knew that we
would have to accommodate for people who
were holding the phone either widescreen
or
vertical um and so i said should i have
two monitors on set should i make sure
that we're shooting lula
and um and that would never happen like
you're you know it's a set so you're
moving at breaking that kind of speed
and so what we did was uh the dpni
and my production designer talked ad
nauseum
you know before day one about um
in prep we spent a lot of time talking
about
what is the most satisfying way to tell
this story
or somebody because i know how to tell a
story horizontally i've never told a
story vertically right
none of us had if you're holding the
phone
like this um
what's the most satisfying way for an
audience to feel like they are getting
the whole entire story
and not missing pieces
because we usually see in wider aspect
ratio
and we're used to seeing that way and if
we don't see that way
we feel like we're losing information
because there have been other series
that tried to do this
vertical storytelling i watched them i
felt like wait i'm
what's going on on the side of the
screen so very um
very quickly realized we couldn't just
say okay
screw you if you're holding it
vertically we don't care just hold it
horizontal horizontally
especially since phones are designed to
be held vertically
so we started to talk about what about
depth you know what about
instead of thinking east west you think
north south
you know or actually i'm sorry you think
a to z
you know so how do i create as much
depth inside the frame because whether
it's horizontal or vertical i'm going to
feel that
and make sure that the information that
audiences get
holding vertically or horizontally is is
constantly at the edges of frames so
that they're never
feeling like they're missing anything so
for example
um we made sure that we pushed aisles
together closer
in in like the gas station you know
there was constantly
layers uh depth layers that we were
shooting through
claire was always moving through spaces
that were interesting
and and and full of like life like the
train station
you know chinatown plaza you know the
train itself you know the chairs
the lights there's always something
moving and giving you more information
the toughest thing is the movie opens up
on two people sitting in a car
so so what we talked about then was
um you know to respect kind of the
the the dark element and the dark tone
of what evolved slowly in that car
between these two people
keep the camera moving but very slowly
and hit different hit the
side of her cheekbone hit the rear-view
mirror where you see your eyes
hit carlos e's eyes you know just keep
kind of
keep the camera moving in ways that
maybe the audience isn't aware of
but they are subconsciously constantly
getting information